il avait annoncé en cas de victoire de
son camp la démission de l'exécutif et
des législatives anticipées
mais le parti de matteo salvini a été
battu par la gauche ce dimanche en
emilie romagne dans le nord du pays
selon des résultats partiels
ce scrutin régional avait valeur de test
national pour le leader souverainiste
italien le président sortant de la
région stefano bonacci ni du parti
démocrate de centre gauche a devancé
avec un score autour de 50% des voix son
adversaire lucia bourgogne zone i
la représentante de la ligue serait elle
créditée d'environ 43% des suffrages
selon les premiers dépouillements des
bulletins de vote
une chose ressort je ne suis pas
intéressé pour commenter les problèmes
des autres
cependant il est clair que l'un des deux
alliés du gouvernement je pense aux
mouvements 5 étoiles si les données sont
confirmées disparaît en grande partie de
la région emilie romagne et il disparaît
également presque de la région de
calabre
deux des régions le mouvement 5 étoiles
est née et où il a recueilli le plus de
voix
il est donc clair que quelque chose va
changer demain à rome
cette élection régionale a été marquée
par une très forte participation de 67%
contre 37 lors du précédent scrutin de
2014 régions prospères du centre nord de
la péninsule l'émilie romagne a
longtemps été un bastion historique de
la gauche
outre la forte affluence aux urnes la
gauche a aussi profité de la dynamique
anti salvi nien créé par les sardines un
mouvement de jeunes nés dans la région
est devenue un symbole national de la
protestation contre la droite
nationaliste mais a indiqué s'attendre à
des résultats il faut dire aussi que ce
fut pour moi un grand résultat
historique
c'est le résultat du nombre d'entre vous
qui êtes ici aujourd'hui et du fait que
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
après 50 ans
cette région était contestable nous
continuerons à travailler
matteo salvini a tenté de se consoler en
se réjouissant de la victoire quasiment
assuré de la candidat de centre droit
jole et santé vie lors d'élections
régionales organisées en calabre
compte tenu de son langage
mon premier plan dans ce scrutin la
défaite en emilie romagne est un revers
important pour la formation
souverainiste
le leader de la ligue espère en effet
une victoire afin de provoquer de
nouvelles élections qui lui permettrait
de revenir aux commandes du pays
au final le chef du gouvernement
giuseppe compter le parti démocrate
devrait être renforcée par cette
victoire de la gauche
[Musique]